thank you
welcome to session 73 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
around we're going to be looking at some
works by Thomas legotti that I'll tell
you about in just a bit for anybody who
is new to the series this is an ongoing
monthly set of examinations of World
building and philosophical themes in
speculative fictions usually spanning a
number of short stories and or novels
and we've been doing this since 2016
when we partnered with the Brookfield
Public Library at first they were
in-person sessions held more or less
each month and then with covid we moved
online into the format that you see at
present where we have a usually I try to
shoot for 90 minute video that premieres
we have live chat this time around it's
going to be a bit longer than that I'm
afraid and then we follow it up with a
more intimate video conferencing session
through Zoom talking with each other
about the the books the ideas following
up and exploring things and even more
depth so this time around as I mentioned
we're doing Thomas lagoti he has been
somebody
requested for quite a long time by fans
suggested by colleagues and so we were
supposed to do him last year he actually
made it in one of the votes that I do
near the end of the year each time
around and we just didn't get to him so
we're doing him this year and I'm
actually this is one of those times when
I'm very happily surprised by the high
quality
of what has been recommended to me
shouldn't be a huge surprise at this
point because nearly all of the
recommendations that I've got have
turned out to be quite excellent but
this is actually something quite
extraordinary I would say and so we're
going to be looking at a number of his
short stories as we find them in several
of his collections
got here his songs of a dead dreamer and
Grim scribe those are his two first
story Collections and you know it's
quite a a volume here we obviously won't
be looking at every single story but
we'll be examining some common themes in
quite a few and then we have some more
recent Works uh noctuary and the very
short the spectral link which only has
two stories both of which I think are
quite important in it and this is
supplemented by a non-fiction book
essentially a work of philosophy that
lagoti wrote a while back called the
conspiracy against the human race
um which has been quite influential not
just in the worlds of uh fiction but
also you know there's quite a few
philosophers that are interested in
checking this out now I titled this
session Thomas legatti's Tales of of uh
philosophical horror but it's also
supernatural horror and we're going to
be looking at his massive articulated
world view which is often summarized as
pessimism sometimes as nihilistic and
how that is going to play out in his
stories which are all within the horror
or weird genre and ligodi himself has a
number of thoughts about this which
we're going to be looking at later on
taken from his own interviews his
biography also plays an important role
so we're going to be spending a good bit
of time looking at that but we're also
going to be exploring some selections of
philosophical themes that are
articulated in conspiracy against the
human race and then found you in his
stories in narrative form there's a few
stories in which he's actually doing
something a bit similar to conspiracy
against the human race but in a smaller
space you could say right and so we'll
also look at some of those stories as
well
and before we look at his biography at
length and the you know let's call it
the effects that uh undergoing various
forms of mental illness or as they used
to call it uh alienation has produced in
his work and you know the backdrop of
his own life and how that plays a role
in in his stories uh and before we go on
to looking at what he says about his own
work through the media of interviews
that is talking with an interlocutor
about things I think that we have to
spend a bit of time since this is Worlds
of speculative fiction talking about not
so much the World building as such
because you could say that what what's
going into the goatee's stories even as
early as these very first collections is
a reflection of what he is articulating
later on in conspiracy against the human
race so I think we probably
ought to in order to set the stage
properly talk about
um World building in relation to deeper
world view where the stories and the
incompletely uh presented world because
we never get some sort of totalizing
vision of everything on the part of
legoti in his stories uh covering every
one of his stories we never get that but
it is undergirded by his as admittedly
pessimistic world view so that's what
we'll go into first as we explore these
uh great works and
um
you know we'll make our way through
obviously we're not going to get to
every single story or even philosophical
Point made in these works but we can
certainly do much more than scratch the
surface I'm going to say one other thing
too by way of um
I guess you could call it narrative
before we jump into this so I had
intended to do this earlier not just in
terms of you know in an earlier year but
an earlier time this month and what I
discovered interestingly perhaps
mysteriously we could even say is that
Thomas lagoti's works are not that easy
to find
in local libraries so you know at the
um really excellent usually Milwaukee
Central Library which is just a
beautiful structure has four levels of
storage tiers full of books down below
they didn't really have too many of his
Works available
um these you know spectral link and
noxuary and then conspiracy against the
human race and I put in a request West
because they do have a copy of this
songs of a dead dreamer and Grim scribe
and it's still out at this point it
hasn't been returned it's overdue and I
couldn't get my hands on it now I have
Library privileges at a local University
Library as well Marquette University
what you got is usually quite excellent
even for fiction works and I went into
the catalog and found that the only book
by lagoti that they actually list as
being in their Holdings is
noctuary they don't even have the
conspiracy against the human race so I
was kind of surprised by this and so we
ended up having to order songs of a dead
dreamer and Grim scribe so that I
wouldn't be simply going by internet
PDFs that I managed to scrape together
and could actually they hold the book in
my hand as I'm talking about it with you
and I'm very happy to have this it's
quite different reading a book as a book
that you have a physical copy of rather
than merely a PDF fact simile so these
are the works that we're going to be
looking at so I hope that you enjoy the
discussion of these works as much as I
and perhaps you enjoy these Works
themselves
what are the features of the narrative
universe that Thomas lagotti has
constructed his short stories and indeed
we could even say his non-fiction work
within there's a show from the 1980s
that I saw as a kid that perhaps some of
you have encountered before but I'm not
recommending the show as such but it had
a really
striking intro and outro that I think
are reflective of Thomas lagatti's
vision of of things as we're going to
look at it in a few of his stories and
his conspiracy against the human race
and that show was called Tales from the
dark side if you haven't seen the intro
Google it and it is very interesting and
creepy and it begins by saying man lives
in the sunlit world of what he believes
to be reality but there is unseen by
most and underworld a place that is just
as real but not as brightly lit a dark
side and with the television thing again
you can look it up you'll see this like
transformation of this nice forest scene
and something
Macabre something uncanny something
scary the closing part again reminiscent
of what's going on in the goatee's works
the dark side is always there waiting
for us to enter waiting to enter us
until next time try to enjoy the
daylight is then how it is framed so
um that's a great way of encapsulating
a good bit of what's going on in
legati's work
and before we look at the conspiracy
against the human race there's a few
let's call them didactic stories that I
think are worth
checking out showing that you know long
before he writes that book A lot of
these ideas are being articulated and so
Professor nobody's little lectures is a
great one and I'm not going to read all
of it although the entire thing is is
well worth reading I'm going to start
with pessimism and supernatural horror
lecture one
Madness chaos bone deep Mayhem
Devastation of innumerable Souls while
we scream and perish history licks a
finger and turns the page fiction unable
to compete with the world for vividness
of pain and lasting effects of fear
compensates in its own way how by
inventing more bizarre means to
outrageous ends among these means of
course is the Supernatural and
transforming natural ordeals into
Supernatural ones we find the strength
to affirm and deny their horror
simultaneously to savor and suffer them
at the same time so this is projecting
supernatural horror as if it's something
that we
we could say create as fictions whether
in literature or in ghost stories or our
own little private mythologies and
experiences and so he goes out and he
says supernatural horror is the product
of a profoundly divided species of being
our being
it is not the Pastime of even our
closest relations in the Holy natural
world
we gained it as part of our gloomy
inheritance when we became what we are
once awareness of the human predicament
was achieved we immediately took off in
two directions splitting ourselves down
the middle
one half became devoted dedicated to
apologetics even celebration of our new
toy of consciousness
the other half condemned and
occasionally launched directs direct
assaults on this gift
now which is supernatural horror well
not not either supernatural horror was
one of the ways we found that would
allow us to live with our double selves
by its employ we discovered how to take
all the things that victimize us in our
natural lives and turn them into the
very stuff of demonic Delight in our
fantasy lives in story and song we could
entertain ourselves with the worst we
could think of overwriting real pains
with ones that were unreal and harmless
to our species we can also do this trick
without trespassing onto the property of
supernatural horror but then we risk
running into miseries that are too close
to home
so that's the first part and then we
have pessimism and supernatural horror
lecture two
and he deepens this analysis he tells us
that
um
the logic of supernatural horror is
founded on fear a logic whose sole
principle states existence equals
nightmare unless life is a dream nothing
makes sense for as a reality it is a
rank failure
and he goes on that we all deserve
punishment by horror is is mystifying as
it is undeniable to become an accomplice
however involuntarily in a reasonless
non-reality is cause enough for the
harshest sentencing but we've been
trained so well to accept the order of
an unreal world we do not rebel against
it how could we where pain and pleasure
form a corrupt alliance against us
paradise and hell are merely different
divisions in the same monstrous
bureaucracy and between these two polls
exists everything we know or can ever
know it is not even possible to imagine
a Utopia Earthly or otherwise I can
stand up under the mildest criticism but
one must take into account the shocking
fact that we live on a world that spins
he goes on and he says on rare occasions
we do overcome hopelessness or vality
and make mutinous demands to live in a
real world one that is at least
episodically ordered to our advantage
but perhaps it is only a demon of some
kind that moves us to such idle
insubordination the more so to aggravate
our condition in the unreal after all is
it not wondrous that we're allowed to be
both Witnesses and victims of the
support
sepulchoral pomp of wasting tissue and
one thing we know is real
so up until this point you know horror
is sort of an escape from the real one
thing we know is real
horror it is so real in fact that we
cannot be sure it could not exist
without us yes it needs our imaginations
and our Consciousness but it does not
ask or require our consent to use them
indeed or operates with complete
autonomy
all said we must face up to it horror is
more real than we are
the last thing I'll read from this very
quickly is just from the final section
sardonic Harmony
it says compassion for human hurt a
humble sense of our impermanence and
absolute valuation of Justice all our
so-called virtues only trouble us and
serve to bolster not a swage horror in
addition these qualities are at least
vital at least in line with life more
often than not they stand in the way of
one's rise in the Welter of the world
which found its Pace long ago and is not
deviated from it since
the putative affirmations of life you to
them based on the propaganda of Tomorrow
reproduction Revolution is widest sense
piety in any form you can name are only
affirmations of our desire so he goes on
and says by means of supernatural horror
we may evade if momentarily the horrific
reprisals of affirmation every one of us
having been stolen from non-existence
opens his eyes on the world and looks
down the road at a few convulsions and a
final obliteration what a weird scenario
so why affirm anything why make a
pathetic virtue of a terrible necessity
and he says since there's no one around
to do the mocking we'll take on the job
let us indulge in Cruel Pleasures
against ourselves and our pretensions
let us Delight in the cosmic Macabre
right so supernatural horror is not
something that is just you know made up
on top of the brutal real world that we
have
it comes out of it as a reflection of
our own Consciousness and our connection
to something more so this is a great
opportunity to look at
um his essay who goes there in um
conspiracy against the human race and
the discussion of The Uncanny and so he
says
um
most of us share a general pattern of
feeling about what is right or wrong in
a moral sense and we also share a
general pattern of feeling about what is
right or wrong and with respect to the
world and ourselves an internal
Authority that judges entities and
events as within or outside the customs
of reality
in experiencing The Uncanny there is a
feeling of wrongness
a violation has transpired that alarms
are internal Authority regarding how
something is supposed to happen or exist
or behave an offense against our world
conception or self-conception has been
committed of course our internal
Authority May itself be in the wrong
perhaps because it is a fabrication of
Consciousness based on a body of laws
that are written only within us and not
a detector of what is right or wrong in
any real sense since nothing really is
right or wrong in any real sense
that we might be wrong about something
being wrong would itself be wrong
according to our internal Authority
which would then send out a signal of
The Uncanny concerning its own wrongness
that would be returned to it for another
round of signaling on the principle that
everything it knows is wrong which is to
say that something is always wrong
for the welfare of our functioning we're
in we're insured against the adverse
effect of an Ever cycling signal of
uncanny wrongness by your inability to
recognize it although it might be going
on all the time thus accounting for our
uneasiness about something
but we may still perceive other
phenomena to be on the wrong side of
right and wrong things that should not
happen or exist or behave in the way we
feel that they should
so very interesting set of observations
there our Consciousness for lagoti goes
out you know and helps form the world
this is very much drawn from people like
schopenhauer and Nietzsche but also you
know according to him uh you know more
recent figures as well including
scientists and we have a world that
certainly has scope for horror and The
Uncanny within it because of the
fundamental
wrongnesses which we have projected out
there
um I'm going to skip back a little bit
into the nightmare of being where he
talks about the motif of supernatural
horror what is it
something terrible in its being comes
forward and makes its claim as a
shareholder in our reality
or what we think is our reality and ours
alone it may be an emissary from the
grave or an esoteric monstrosity it may
be the offspring of a scientific
experiment with unintended consequences
or uh it may be a hideous token of
another dimension revealed only in a
Mythic home as in the yellow sign or it
may be a world onto itself of pure
morbidity one suffused with a profound
sense of Doom without a name Edgar Allan
Poe's world then he goes on
reflected in the world works of many
Supernatural writers the signature Motif
schopenhauer made discernible in
pessimism was most consistently
promulgated by Lovecraft Paragon among
literary figures who have thought the
unthinkable or at least thought what
most Mortals do not want to think in
conceiving azathoth that nuclear chaos
which Bubbles at the center of all
eternity Lovecraft May well have been
thinking of schopenhauer's will as
instantiated in lovecraft's Stories the
pernicious something that makes a
nightmare of our world is individuated
into linguistically teterological
entities from Beyond or outside of our
universe
like ghosts or the undead their very
existence Spooks us as a violation of
what should and should not be suggesting
unknown modes of being an uncanny
Creations which epitomize supernatural
horror
let's come back to uh
the uh stories one of the interesting
stories that he has in songs of a dead
dreamer is called notes on the writing
of horror a story and he actually after
giving us a scary story about a bad pair
of pants
He suggests that there are three styles
that we can work in the realistic
technique
which uh you know essentially starts out
with a world that we know and you know
things emerge from that but eventually
go back into the realism that we started
from the traditional Gothic technique as
he calls it and then finally the
experimental technique and he will
finish by saying that
all the Styles we've examined uh have
been purified for the purposes of
instruction each is a simplified example
in the real world of horror fiction
these three techniques often get
entangled with one another and
hopelessly strange ways almost to the
point of rendering my previous
discussion of them useless but an
ulterior purpose which I'm saving for
later may be better served
I'd like to briefly propose another
Style
right
he says that
um
the story of Nathan is one very close to
my heart I wanted to write this horror
Tale in such a fashion as readers would
be distressed not by the isolated
catastrophe of Nathan
but by the very existence of a world
where such catastrophe is possible
I wanted to forge a tale that would
conjure a mournful Universe independent
of time place and persons
the characters of the story would be
death itself and the flesh desire in a
new pair of pants desiderata within
Arm's Reach and doom in a size to fit
all and he says well I couldn't do this
let's talk about the final style then he
says
uh the the narrator talks about
revealing my own Prejudice concerning
how a Horror Story should be written and
he says
horror has a voice proper to itself but
what is it is is it that of an old
Storyteller uh is it uh that of a
documentarian or is it the yarn spinning
God who can see the unseeable and
narrates from an omniscient perspective
a scary set of incidents and he says no
it's none of those voices is instead
it's a lonely voice calling out in the
middle of the night sometimes it's
muffled like the voice of a tiny insect
crying for help from inside a sealed
coffin at a time the coffin shatters and
from within rise is a piercing Crystal
shriek that lacerates the midnight
blackness in other words the proper
voice of horror is really that of
personal
confession and he says horror is not
really horror unless it's your horror
that which you have known personally you
may not be able to get it out of a
consummately profound way but this is
where true horror writing must start and
what makes it true is that the
confessing narrator always has something
he must urgently get off his chest and
labors beneath its nightmarish wait all
the while while he's telling the tale so
interestingly at least in the the
presentation of that narrator
horror is going to to be something
personal now the goatee thinks that we
don't actually have selves in any true
philosophical way as we'll talk about a
bit later so we can ask well what what
is it and that's where the who goes
there with the reference interestingly
to the story that would eventually spawn
the film The Horror the horror film uh
the thing uh winds up being there what
am I and we discover ourselves in the
world through horror he is maintaining
coming back to the conspiracy against
the human race there's there's one other
section that I want to bring up
and this is in sick to death right and
he tells us this is at the very end of
the essay by means of supernatural
horror we may evade if momentarily the
horror of the horrific reprisals of
affirmation every one of us
having been stolen from non-existence
opened his eyes on the world looks down
the road at a few convulsions at a final
obliteration this is The Bleak
nihilistic Viewpoint right what a weird
scenario so why affirm anything why make
a pathetic virtue of a terrible
necessity we are destined to a Fool's
faith that deserves to be mocked and
since there's no one around to do it
right
um this is we've already talked about
this a little bit right so supernatural
horror as he's gonna finish he says
enables a reader to taste treats
inconsistent with his personal welfare
now
are is all horror like that the the
schlocky stuff
is scary but doesn't really affect us
long term
the reason why legottis work and the
work of those who he lauds as great
horror writers for instance Lovecraft
and Poe and others like that can have
such a profound impact is because it
reveals to us a world that is certainly
fiction right but is a fiction in which
we can perhaps
imaginatively and emotionally enter and
a world that we find doesn't work out
the way it ought to
um I'm going to close this by bringing
up a story that that legati says is is
you know very important for him the
shadow at the bottom of the world which
is coming from Grim scribe so there's a
scarecrow and weird things are happening
around it so they go and they start
tearing away the coverings of the
Scarecrow and what is found
um
here we go
there's a long description
from the skeleton of the thing for the
skeleton the thing should have been
merely two crosswise planks the shape
that stood before us was of a wholly
different nature it was something black
and twisted into the form of a man
something that seemed to have come up
out of the earth and grown over the
wooden planks like a dark fungus
consuming the structure there were now
black legs that hung as if charred and
withered there was a head that sagged
like a sack of Ashes upon a meager body
of Blackness there were thin arms
stretched like knobby branches from a
lightning Scorch tree all of this was
supported by a thick dark stalk which
rose from the earth and reached into the
Effigy like a hand into a puppet very
important theme that we're going to look
at later the notion of the puppet
and he says its composition appeared to
be of the blackest Earth of Earth that
had gone stagnant somewhere in its
depths where a rich loam infested into a
bog of Shadows
even when we venture to lay our hands on
the mass of Darkness we found only
greater Mysteries they they're unable to
destroy it and then what ends up
happening is they start digging around
the earth they dug very deep but it
wasn't enough to reach the bottom of
that sprouting blackness
our attempts became hindered by a
perverse reluctance in the instance of
someone who's hesitant to have a disease
part of his own body cut away in order
to keep the disease from spreading
so they come back later and what
happened it's gone the farmer revealed
to us gone into the into the Earth like
something hiding in its shell don't walk
there we gathered about the edge of this
opening in the ground gazing into its
depths even full Daybreak did not show
us the bottom of that dark well our
speculations were brief and futile some
of us picked up the shovels lying nearby
as if to begin the long duty of filling
in the great aperture no use in that so
the farmer he then found a large Stone
and dropped it straight down the shaft
we waited and waited we put our heads
close to the hole and listened but all
we seemed to hear were remote humming
Echoes as of countless voices of insects
chattering unseen
and uh you know so we've got here a bot
you know seemingly bottomless hits right
and eventually
what is going to happen is this thing
will walk uh by them again and we we
hear this interesting thing
we knew what needed to happen a season
was Upon Us of all seasons and an
aberration had risen that did not belong
to the course of life we had always
known it grew out of the Earth in a
farmer's field and beneath it was a
bottomless hole that we covered with a
mound of dirt thereby denying a
hungering presence what it asked of us
unsated it would now take what it
desired as frightened as we were we also
felt resentment and outrage from the
beginning there was an exchange to which
we'd resigned ourselves that which is
given must one day be given back the
course of Life In Time the Eternal
Darkness would arrive as each of Our
Lives was reclaimed at its end and went
back to the Earth that had borne our
bodies and sustained them with its
plenty
but the phenomenon we confronted seemed
nothing less than a premature craving
agreed surpassing our covenant with
Earth's estate what we were forced to
stipulate then
was another perhaps more fundamental
order of being than our species had
suspected even a betrayal or deception
on the part of creation itself all that
was left to us was to wonder who knows
all that is innate to this world or to
any other
why should there not be something buried
deep within appearances
something that wears a mask to hide
itself behind the visibility of nature
so closing on this supernatural horror
sort of like we can go down rabbit holes
well rabbit holes may turn out not to be
just
mere rabbit holes and something else may
come up as going back to this sometimes
we discover the dark side sometimes the
dark side discovers us and enters into
us but that's a reflection of an unseen
order
that is more you know fundamental than
what our consciousnesses project outward
and what our society constantly churns
to keep us at ease and to keep all of
these Reflections at Bay so a little bit
of the landscape of legati's narratives
encapsulated in that obviously there's
much more yet to explore
with any author who we haven't already
covered in the worlds of speculative
fiction series we want to delve into
their biography a bit not just for the
trivia of you know when this book was
published or what award they won but to
get a better sense of who they are as an
author and the influences the
experiences the setbacks the successes
and with lagoti this is very important
as we're going to find out he's a living
author but he's rather
reclusive so this gives us some sort of
insight that we can draw in part from
you know various biographies that are
out there on the internet but also from
interviews with him and even some stuff
that's coming from the outside as we're
going to see so lagoti is born in
Detroit Michigan in 1953 so this is a
time when Detroit is is sort of at the
peak of its success as a city if you
don't know much about Detroit it is a
cautionary tale for the Midwest Rust
Belt at one time Detroit was the fourth
largest city in the United States
and it's now you know it's not a
wasteland as such but it's a city with
many many challenges and the decline
took several decades and there have been
efforts to try to reverse it but none of
them have been entirely successful so
this is part of what shapes lagoti he's
born to Gasper and Dolores ligodi second
generation uh he's a second generation
American of predominantly Sicilian
heritage
as a young boy he was hospitalized and
operated on for an abdominal rupture and
he also tells us that um in one of his
interviews I was a fairly devout
Catholic as a child less so as a
teenager not at all since my late teens
he he talks about this in some of his
essays you know a sense of Catholic
worry and guilt being sort of you know
brought into his existence he talks
about this in interviews as well and
then he said that after that he got into
you know this or that this or that sort
of Eastern Doctrine one Guru after
another he would get excited with a new
spiritual toy and then become border
irritated and then lapsing back into
nothing so he says I took religion very
seriously as a child but abandoned it in
my late teens and he also tells us that
he was born in Detroit but he didn't
grow up in Detroit itself he grew up in
an upper class last suburb that bordered
on Detroit but he says during High
School in the 1960s I spent some time
hanging out in dope houses in Detroit's
ghettos and he also worked in downtown
Detroit for 23 years and he he got into
drinking and Drugs in part to have some
sort of excitement but also to deal with
some of the problems that he was already
experiencing and to try to you know try
them out so he says that
between uh 11th and 12th grades he had
sort of worked himself out of that why
because he says I hardly left the house
except to attend school why because my
panic attacks and agoraphobia were very
severe and frequent so already in his
teenage years he's experiencing what we
would nowadays call a psychological
episodes or disorders and at this time
at a visit during the local drug story
found in a Book Stall The Works of
Arthur machen and you know this is a
weird horror writer right and why in a
drugstore because back then and this is
part of my childhood growing up in the
70s and 80s you would go to the
drugstore and there would be racks of
books some of them would be like romance
novels or mercenary stuff but there was
lots of sci-fi
and fantasy and horror things that you
could buy and it was it was kind of a
common place to actually get your hands
on these so he does that and then the
next year he discovers HP Lovecraft and
decides that he wants to write himself
in 1971 he actually graduates from Gross
Point North High School and he begins
going to the Macon County Community
College where he is for about two years
and then begins his studies in English
at Wayne State University in Detroit
right which runs from 1973 to 1978 and
he says that around this time he began
writing and you know interestingly
enough where would he submit his stuff
Arkham house they reject everything
Arkham house why that because it's it's
a place founded by August duralith among
others that publishes
a number of weird authors but especially
HP Lovecraft and then he says there was
a period so this is part of his uh
College times from 1975 to 1979 when I
was severely depressed in addition to my
Panic anxiety disorder so he's got got a
new thing to deal with says I was a
hedonic all all day every day I thought
my existence was over but I was young
and it was during that period I began to
write in Earnest years went by and he's
very Frank about this and I wrote One
Bad story after another then I wrote the
last Feast of harlequin whose narrator
is a depressive it was very bad but not
so bad that I destroyed it I kept it in
an old beer case I used to Archive my
writing every so often I'd read it over
again thinking how I could extract the
good parts from the bad and in the
meantime I began writing stories that
were published in small press magazines
now he uh
does some work uh you know as a teaching
assistant under the comprehensive
educational training act in in Michigan
as well in Oak Park and then he gets a
job at Gale research company uh Gail the
publisher and he has a number of
different jobs he's an editorial
assistant then he becomes an assistant
editor senior assistant editor associate
editor and this is you know fairly
quickly these are year by year and in
the course of that his first published
story The chemist appears in 1981 and he
wins uh from small press writers and
artists organization best author of
horror weird fiction and in 1982 and
then in 1983 he goes to the world
fantasy convention in Ottawa Canada
doing a little bit of travel for that
and he's continuing to write and now
he's getting some traction while still
working at Gale and he publishes songs
of a dead dreamer in 1985 a short story
collection right and
um he's going to start having some
interesting progress Grim scribe his
lives and works 1991 but I want to focus
on something else that he brought up in
in another interview said I was drawn to
popular music from an early age I asked
for a transistor radio for my birthday
once in order to listen to baseball
games I also listen to hockey games
while lying in bed on Sunday nights
because it was the only Sports Broadcast
at the time it was depressing listening
to broadcasts of hockey a game in which
I had no interest but I had to listen to
something to take my mind off starting
another week the next day like many
people I found both Sundays and school
depressing Monday wasn't that great
either coming Tuesday I felt bad better
and so I started to listen to local
radio shows that played popular music
and he says all afterwards I stopped
listening to sports and only listened to
music this was in the early 60s and I
retained Nostalgia for songs of that
period especially songs that had what I
perceived as haunting melodies or
instrumental hooks here's where things
change a bit
I took up guitar and played lead in a
band throughout Junior High and most of
high school we played an incredible
variety of songs throughout that period
and had a particular liking for The
Loving Spoonful then came Blues Blues
rocks psychedelia we became a jam band
I had an Unholy Terror of performing in
public but I loved music so much I put
up with the anxiety
music ended for me when I had an
emotional breakdown and started having
multiple panic attacks every day I
didn't pick it up again until College
when I took courses in theory sight
singing ear training all that stuff I
was terrified every day everyone in
class was a music Major except me I
worked far more at music than I did at
literature and language what he was
supposed to be studying
I started playing classical guitar I
also played electric guitar at home and
taught guitar at a music studio for some
years is one of my jobs to pay for
college I never performed in public
again except in music classes and then
he says in 1975 I stopped listening to
music altogether when my first
Depression hit I had only all right that
lasted for years sometime later in the
70s I began to feel better and started
reading and writing every free moment so
that's what leads him into his work
um
so in in 1991 another sort of very
important year he wins the world fantasy
Award for best short fiction for the
last Feast of harlequin and brings out
Grimm scribe his second collection and
then he says in 1991 I decided to call
it quits as a writer but I had to do
something so I started playing guitar
again
um thinking it would be a less stressful
activity I became a complete guitar geek
and it wasn't any less stressful than
writing this is around 1993 and here we
get another interesting turn when the
company I worked for was going through a
reorganization not its first I think of
1993 1994 as the time when people
working in offices realized their
potential for being that second
reorganization Disturbed me so much with
its blatant idioces and pod people
mentality I wrote The Nightmare Network
now I was writing again and playing
guitar on top of that the situation at
work kept escalating and it's Madness
and pothos and I wrote another corporate
horror story called I have a special
plan for this world by then a number of
my co-workers actually felt I was going
off my rocker and feared that I would do
something I didn't feel I was at that
stage yet it wasn't until 2000 several
reorganizations later that I began to
lose and I became obsessed by violent
fantasies these became the impetus for
writing my work is not yet done which
we'll get to in just a bit
in the meantime in the 90s he publishes
noctuary which we're going to look at a
little bit here in just a bit the
agonizing resurrection of Victor
Frankenstein and other Gothic tales and
then in 1996 the nightmare factory comes
out now the nightmare factor is a
consolidation uh an Omnibus from the
first three Collections and then there's
a concluding section that has new
stories which are then going to be
reprinted later on and this wins the
Bram Stoker award for uh you know
collection and also it when the one of
the stories the red Tower wins the Bram
Stoker award for short fiction he also
wins the British fantasy Award for best
fiction collection so this is really
putting legotti on the map
then something else very interesting
happens
1997 he publishes in a foreign town in a
foreign land and this begins his
association with David tibet's band
current 93 and so that work is
accompanied by a CD as is also going to
be the case for I have a special plan
for this world this degenerate little
town and the Unholy City published in in
2000 2001 and 2002. now in 2001 shortly
after that other reorganization in 2000
lagoti says undone he leaves Gail he
moves to Florida and actually you know
as we find out he has uh some of the
family down there and
um shortly after that my work is not
done three Tales of corporate horror
comes out in 2002 and he does write a
few other stories our temporary
supervisor my case for retributive
action but those are written later they
don't make it into that that volume and
my work has not yet done wins uh Bram
Stoker Award for best long fiction uh
and it also wins a horror Guild award
for the long-form category
in the meantime in 2003
um he well not he but but a publisher
dutoro publishes Crampton a screenplay
now this is actually
originally a X-Files episode which never
gets produced or published or anything
like that but it gets transformed into a
feature length script with lagoti and
Brandon trents and so he says by you
know 19 the 1990s I was watching The
X-Files and Brandon had this idea for
the opening to an X-Files episode and
you know it sounded like a good episode
thing we could develop it into a script
I was no longer by 1996 a regular viewer
and I didn't really care that much about
it but I wasn't writing that much in
horror fiction and I thought maybe I'd
write stop writing altogether so you
know in order to keep myself from
contemplating my death I began and
became involved with branded in
developing this script and it does get
published in 2003 also in 2003 Sideshow
and Other Stories and then death poems
lugoti actually writes poetry and then
he writes the shadow at the bottom of
the world and publishes that in
2005. the nightmare factory extra
materials toward the end gets
republished as Teatro
grotesco in 2006 and interestingly what
we find you know it sounds like he's
doing professional writing but actually
in 2007 we find in in an interview he
says for the past few years I've worked
at home as a freelance copy editor and
he tells us what he's been
doing during the day people send me
editorial projects either by mail or
email I wake up in the morning and
within five minutes I'm sitting in front
of my computer with a cup of coffee it's
intense work and I can't do it for more
than five or six hours at a stretch by
then I'm pretty burnt out I take a long
nap in the afternoon to recover when I
wake up there's emails to answer that
takes an hour or so my bro my mother and
brother live within walking distance and
I usually have dinner with them and
spend the rest of the evening watching
TV with them then I go home and answer
more emails what you don't notice in
there is here's my routine for writing
my stories right so
um it's quite interesting to see that
he's making his living after leaving
Gail by doing all this freelance work
and then what we're going to see leading
up to the conspiracy against the the
human race which is a work of
non-fiction right
more or less
um lagoti is exam he's engaging in what
he calls the examination of the
philosophy of Madness and he says it
reached its Apec in 2000 he finished a
major paper around the philosophy the
experience of time in psychosis and the
steady flow of philosophical
deliberation on the subject of psychosis
swept me away that summer and plunged me
into the heart of the object itself a
full-blown acute psychosis and so he's
got now yet another thing that he's he's
struggling with and he says that you
know I demonstrate how my own
philosophical attitude led to psychotic
Praxis and I argue this is a more common
occurrence that is a certain kind of
consistent philosophizing may very well
result in confusion paradoxes unworldly
insights and circular Frozen that is
reminiscent of Madness which in fact
happened to quite a few philosophers who
are far from unimportant now notice who
he actually mentions here
such as Thomas Aquinas what is he
thinking about Thomas aquinas's end of
life experience Friedrich nature
Nietzsche of course went insane uh and
was uh institutionalized right and Georg
kontor now Contour is actually a
mathematician but you know he's willing
to count count him as a philosopher
perhaps because of his work on on
Infinity and trans-finite numbers right
conspiracy against the human race comes
out in 2010 and this is you know
retrospectively it's it's lagoti
revealing his own views on life
Consciousness free will all sorts of
things and it helps us understand his
own work but it's also going to Spur a
lot of other interesting things and this
wins another Bram Stoker award for
Superior achievement in non-fiction then
we have the spectral link coming out in
2014 again we'll be looking at a bit of
that in 2014 something else happens
that's quite interesting True Detective
season one comes out right
and because of the character played by
Matthew McConaughey who you know says
some nihilistic things
fans of lagoti noticed that this is very
similar to what lagoti is saying in the
conspiracy against the human race
and they start going after the
showrunner and writer nick uh pizzolato
and so here's an excerpt from from uh
the um
uh Lovecraft easing website Mike Davis
says I became increasingly uneasy it
seemed to me that True Detective writer
Nick pizzolato was borrowing words and
phrasing from other authors especially
Thomas lagoti I expressed my concerns on
one of the Lovecraft easy in video shows
and then I was contacted by John Paget
the founder of the website Thomas lagoti
online as I reviewed John's research and
did more of my own my doubts I had about
plagiarism disappeared it became obvious
to me that pizzolato had plagiarized
Thomas lagoti and others in some places
using exact quotes in others changing a
word here and there paraphrasing in much
the same way a high school student will
cheat on an essay by copying somebody
else's work and substituting a few words
of their own now pizzolato didn't credit
and eventually he starts getting asked
questions about this and he'll say oh
well I was influenced by him this is an
homage and everyone else is calling BS
on that and saying you can look at what
uh this character is saying and you can
look at what lagoti's saying and it's
almost a word for word correspondence
clearly plagiarism right
going on also in 2014 born fear
interviews with Thomas lagoti comes out
and then the um the songs of a dead
dreamer and Grim scribe again in 2015
republishing and then in 2019 very cool
he wins a lifetime achievement uh Bram
Stoker award in
uh 2021 we get a chat book reprint of
one story published in the spectral link
the small people which we're going to
talk about in in a bit uh and then
there's another uh chat book uh
paradoxes from Holland 2021 and then the
most uh recent 2023 pictures of
Apocalypse new poems coming out
loogoti continues to publish uh quite
often in weird Tales Magazine and he's
he also writes like uh stories for
Anthology so we might see some more uh
you know books of his short stories
coming out in the future we can look
forward to that and I want to close here
with something about influence and
um you know the extent of of reading of
lagoti and so this is coming from Jeff
Vandermeer and vulture uh magazine he
says that ligodi has been relegated to
the status of a cult author his cause
taken up by a devoted but small fan base
and that cause hasn't been helped by
four distinct factors one is lagoti's
not dead yet
um the second is he only writes short
fiction
the third is he's notoriously reclusive
in our social media age where if you
really want to get out there I mean just
to give you an idea if you're going to
try to write a book proposal as a new
author one of the first things that
they're going to want in that is how
many followers you have in social media
and Facebook Twitter Instagram YouTube
Etc right legode doesn't do that sort of
thing and he's not going out there to
the conventions or anything like that
and then finally despite being
championed by editors at virgin and
Carolyn Graf he hasn't had a mainstream
literary publisher give him the push
needed to reach a wider audience and
that's also perhaps a reflection of the
current status of uh popular publishing
right Publishers expect the authors to
do more and more of the publicity work
and Logo he's just not interested in
that and you know how would he be
interested in that given some of the
things that he has consistently
struggled with his entire life and his
clear you know statements that I want to
do this I'm not interested in doing this
thing over here so there's the biography
I think that gives you a good sense of
who this guy Thomas lagotti is now we're
going to look at some interviews that
reveal what he thinks about his own work
and many other topics
Thomas lagoti has given a number of
interviews over the course of his long
and still ongoing career and so I
thought it would be useful as we often
do with these to look at some of the
things that he reveals about his own
point of view his writing process what
he values and how his writing fits in
with his overall let's call it world
view and I wanted to begin with an
interesting just portions of an
interview from the Lovecraft easy and so
you know Lovecraft is of course a very
influential writer for Thomas legati and
what they did is they asked some weird
fiction writers and editors to send one
question each in for Thomas legati to
which he responded in some cases at
considerable length in other cases with
just a few sentences so
Jeffrey Ford wrote although you are most
associated these days with the fiction
of H.P Lovecraft the manner in which you
employ dark humor in your stories one of
my favorite aspects of the work is more
reminiscent of Poe what part overall
does humor play in your work Poe also is
somebody that lagatti talks about quite
a bit and here's what legati said
I don't think of humor as a discrete
element in anything I've written I do
think of it organic to a number of my
later stories these are often works that
have been influenced by Thomas Bernhard
whose fictions and plays provide a good
many Chuckles of deranged sort on every
page to some degree this is also a
quality of some of the works of Franz
Kafka some of his friends have heard him
read from his Works have written that he
giggled all the while I can imagine
doing the same in Reading from some of
my own stories in an email exchange some
years ago I was asked about the humor in
my stories and my answer was that the
humor makes the Blackness blacker still
that sounded true to me at the time and
I think there was some element of truth
to it as I previously remarked I intend
the humor in my writing and that
includes the conspiracy against the
human race to be organic not Advent
I think that any humorous effect in my
stories and in conspiracy may be a
function of exaggerating a grim or
nihilist idea or theme humor of this
kind often appears in my interviews
though I don't think it has arisen very
much in this one I'm not sure why that
is it's quite possible that in
responding to the questions by writers
of works I know to be praiseworthy I've
attempted to come across it's more
sophisticated than light-hearted in my
responses
and then he goes on and he says as far
back as I can remember a good many
people have remarked on my comic remarks
and clownishness I'm not aware of using
humor as a mechanism to engage others
into being well disposed towards me that
may be true but I think it's actually an
integral part of my nature at the same
time my humor in everyday life has it
has had its origin and suffering I'm
often funniest when I feel terrible this
connects with humor and my stories being
organic to their gloomy subjects it's
not exactly Gallows humor though it
sometimes arises in dark contexts I
suppose an example at least I hope
that's an example of this type of humor
would be in my repetition of the words
Beef Pork goat in the clown puppet it's
the word goat in this sequence that
makes it funny to my mind I actually saw
a meat store in a salami area of Detroit
that advertised an inventory of beef
pork and goat I made a mental note to
use those words in a story someday which
I did maybe the eating of goat isn't
funny to some people but I found it a
riot I repeated those words under my
breath for the rest of the day goat
right so I think this is actually quite
an interesting observation right
there is a possibility of responding to
a dark world to feeling uh the effects
of depression to you know seeing others
kind of ambling through the tough-minded
individuals as William James would have
called them and having a laugh about it
right not necessarily in the sense of
engaging in comedy for its own sake or
deliberate humor but a laugh as a
response to the very problem of life
let's go on
he's asked
please expand on your interest in
philosophy I'm interested to know if
there are other thinkers apart from
Sharon and schopenhauer whose ideas you
find useful and I love this response on
his his part lagoda is very pragmatic
and very honest
unpretentious entirely about his
interest in use of philosophy what does
he say
I have no interest in philosophy as such
but only in specialized problems that
Loom large in the thought of some
philosophers and philosophical writers
these problems are relatively few and
are related to one another generally
they would be classed as existential
though for the the most part in a common
sensical manner rather than that has to
do with persons and phenomena in a
everyday ordinary sense and not as
abstract things that exist only within a
wholly conceptual system
so I'm no more interested in
understanding nagarjuna's concept of
emptiness than I am in Martin
Heidegger's concept of Dawson
hypothetically such matters are supposed
to help me understand who I am and what
the world is practically they do not
further for me or to me any such
understanding but only provide any
idiosyncratic ways of talking about who
I am and what the world is it's as if
they subscribe to the balmo of Oscar
Wilde that he lived in fear of not being
misunderstood as if even that much could
be established I wish I could say it's
just me but it isn't therefore and in
brief they do not efficiently touch on
what I experience and how I function as
a cogitating organism it's not
mysterious then that I have an interest
in more Earthly and visceral modes of
specialized problems one of them being
the problem of Consciousness I feel that
there is such a thing as Consciousness
and that I experience it in various ways
I take it personally that I exist at all
and having a comprehension of the role
Consciousness plays and how I feel I
exist is important and interesting to me
and then he talks about Chalmers and
Dennett I'm going to skip over that a
little bit
um but I'll sum it up with this at some
point in the history of some much
discussed problem someone comes along
and says the problem is incoherent
doesn't deserve the attention it's
gotten there are of course about a
billion other theories of consciousness
and then it goes on and says
I lost my interest in logic in school
and not because I didn't do well on the
subject
I can't imagine being engaged by the
thought of a philosopher like Quine who
thought a philosophy is a kind of helper
discipline only useful only in
furthering the purposes of Science and
though I studied the system shop and how
it worked out in the world as well and
representation to both explain how we
could know the nature of const thing in
itself and why it was complicit in the
world being such a crummy place for
human beings
I didn't care and I wasn't convinced by
the former but only cared about the
pessimistic conclusions derived from its
speculations
as advertised in the subtitle the
conspiracy against the human race I was
developing a quote contrivance of horror
and I used the ideas of others whose
thoughts and emotions Advanced my own in
different ways
I didn't use the ideas of thinkers who
didn't interest me and didn't officially
address specialized problems that
concerned me
now I hope what I've written above
conveys a rough idea why I'm not
interested in philosophy there are other
philosophers and philosophical writers
who interest me besides the ones
mentioned in the conspiracy of the human
race uh and he says you know actually
it's possible that aside from those
philosophers I've read every philosopher
who could possibly interest me with the
exception of untranslated philosophers
or whom I would find useful in some way
philosophers who don't interest me are
professionals like I don't know slavo
Zizek or philosophers associated with
the Indescribable Continental School
plus any philosopher that would interest
them going back a couple hundred years
or so so
you know it's very clear from not just
stories but particularly a conspiracy
against the human race that uh you know
lagoti has indeed not just read but
drawn from philosophers quite
extensively but he's not interested in
being a philosopher for the sake of
being a philosopher it mentions you know
a number of people who he doesn't
consider to be particularly helpful or
interesting but he's perfectly fine to
let other people read that stuff if they
want to
then we get a very interesting uh
interview in fantastic Metropolis
between lagoti and nettle ayad and ayad
says do you consider yourself a horror
writer I see your writing in the writing
of some of your contemporaries uh d.f
Lewis and Mark Samuels come to mind is
forming part of a Continuum of the weird
but not necessarily what most people
think of horror writing that has its
roots in Poe and Lovecraft and legati
says
it's interesting that you should mention
the above two authors because I
considered mentioning them with respect
to this question however I don't know
enough about either of them to pronounce
them as troubled in the sense at Poe and
lovecraftwear Lewis has a family
something that pretty much disqualifies
him from the degree of alienation
required to be included in the group of
authors I mentioned none of whom were
breeders as for whether or not I
consider myself a horror writer I would
assert for better for worse I'm one of
the few living individuals who actually
is a horror writer and nothing else that
isn't that a striking claim of
Allegiance a self-identification
um I had follows up what is it about
novels that turns you off that novels
need morals lagoti says yeah something
like that
people will accept a short horror story
that ends badly they won't accept this
in a horror novel not after they've read
so many hundreds of pages
horror stories in the short form are
like campfire Tales or urban legends
that are just a way of saying boo
they have nothing to do with the real
world and the minds of most readers
nevertheless I think there's a great
potential in horror fiction that isn't
easily available to realistic fiction
this is the potential to portray our
worst nightmares both private and public
as we approach death through the decay
of our bodies then to leave it at that
no Happy Endings no apologies no excuses
No Redemption No Escape
some horror writers have done this
consistently
but not many I've been entertained by
The Works of these writers it's Show
Business after all and beyond that I
felt a momentary satisfaction that
someone could be so audacious as to
speak ill of the precious gift of life
when we're all brainwashed from
childhood never to utter a discouraging
word
of course it's not really possible to
avoid affirming life even when you're
writing a horror story to faming it the
act of writing is an affirmation as is
the act of suicide both are vital and
idealistic gestures
Joseph Conrad said that he's shunned the
supernatural because it wasn't necessary
to depict the horror of existence I wish
he hadn't because the Supernatural is
the metaphysical counterpart of insanity
the best possible vehicle for conveying
The Uncanny nightmare of a conscious
mind marooned for a brief while in this
haunted house of a world and being
driven slowly driven manned by the
ghastliness of it all not the man's
Humanity inhumanity to man sort of thing
but a necessary derangement a high order
of weirdness and desolation built into
the system in which we all function
its emblem is the empty and inexplicable
malignity that some of us see in the
faces of dolls mannequins puppets and
the like the faces of so many Effigies
of our own shape made by our own hands
and Minds seem to be our own our way of
telling ourselves that we know a secret
that is too terrible to tell the horror
writer has the best chance of expressing
something of that secret it's really a
lost opportunity or perhaps a blessing
that so few take advantage of this
potential that lies in horror fiction
instead they do the opposite they
discover all the secrets and how trivial
they are a stake through the heart of
silver bulleted exorcism we win all is
well nighty night
then I had asked another really
important question you're
extraordinarily Frank in your discussion
of depression and its effect on your
quality of life it's something that a
lot of people still seem to consider
taboo and legari says mental illness
will remain taboo until it becomes
Universal not that it isn't already
Universal from a certain perspective but
the very existence of the mentally and
emotionally perturbed is a genuine
threat to the socioeconomic system in
which we are imprisoned if you're going
to be crazy your craziness better take
the same form as that of your boss the
law enforcement authorities and the
president of the United States otherwise
you're screwed
Ayah then asks
um have you ever written anything that
you consider too dark or too heavy to
publish
and the Gotti says
no but I've conceived of stories that
were just too disturbing for me to write
Now isn't that interesting
we we don't get uh
unpublished stories they're they're not
even
articulated onto the page he says if you
can write something then it's only so
disturbing anything truly disturbing
can't even be written even if it could
no one could stand to read it and
writing is essentially a means of
entertainment for the writer and the
reader I don't I don't care who the
writer is literature is entertainment or
it is nothing
isn't that another interesting way of
saying things right
and then finally this I think is a
really important Point particularly for
this worlds of speculative fiction where
we do seek out sort of a common
narrative Universe he's asked
do your share do your stories share a
common geography I get the feeling that
uh and he names a bunch of different
um stories are all taking place in the
same region being set in different parts
of the same city and that you know the
the shadow being set in a farming
community in the area just outside of
the city
so what does legati say
I've been obsessed with the settings of
my stories since I began writing I knew
I didn't want to use actual places and
place names for the most part at the
same time I didn't want to invent
fictional settings that paralleled
actual places or worlds that were wholly
fantastic and scrupulously detailed like
those of Mervin Peak or James Branch
Cabell but I didn't I especially didn't
want the burden of trying to emulate
reality I don't know much about reality
in the conventional sense anyway I can't
remember things the way that realistic
writers seem so Adept at doing I've been
a agoraphobic since I was 17 so I
haven't seen much of the world and I
really deplore research as a stage in
writing fiction
what I wanted ultimately was to set my
stories in places as I saw them in my
imagination rather than describing them
from personal observation so in the
sense
that the stories are set in my head
rather than in any detailed World either
real or fantastic I suppose they are all
part of the same
geography so what unites the stories is
legati's own sensibility his own
intellect his own imagination his own
obsessions and the fact that he's
willing to write them down so there is a
shared geography
there's another great interview with
wonder book where he's asked the
question
why do you write
and he says since I was a child I've
used my imagination to escape from life
at the same time my imagination has
plagued me with both reality-based
anxieties as well as anxieties based
entirely in the imagination like the
fear of hell I was taught to him by the
Catholic Church
paired with a talent for literary
composition
a talent it took me over 10 years to
refine I became a writer of horror
stories to my mind writing is the most
important form of human expression not
only artistic writing but also
philosophical writing critical writing
art as such especially programmatic
music such as operas seems trivial to me
by comparison how much however much
pleasure we may get from it writing is
the most effective way to express and
confront the full range of the realities
of life
and so you know this tells you why he's
he's engaged in it and he says that you
know in college I veered from literature
to music for a few years which is the
main reason it took me six years to get
an undergraduate degree in Liberal Arts
I've Loved music for as long as I can
remember since my instrument is the
guitar I know every form and style and
its history and I've written the
classical acoustic and electric forms of
this instrument I think because I have
such a love and understanding of music
I realized to my grief it's limitations
writing is less Limited in the
consolations it offers who have lost a
great deal in their life
then he's asked
to what extent are your stories dark
Mysteries do you ever think of them that
way that their Explorations are the
mysterious and so how does that affect
how you structure them and then he says
well many of my stories have been in
fact explorations of something
mysterious I've sensed behind the show
of physical reality The Works of the
French symbolist by way of Poe
demonstrated the validity of this
approach to writing the shadow at the
bottom of the world was my attempt to
explore the sensations instilled in Me
by the season of autumn but those
Sensations were subjective unreal and
only conveyed my own psychological
disposition consequently
the story was just another fictional
display of my Grim philosophy of
existence later in my life neither
Autumn or any other season filled me
with a sense of mystery due to ahedonia
which reduces the visible world to its
physical appearances and nothing more
and uh he's asked how does the
inexplicable inform your fiction and
then he says it doesn't at least as far
as I can tell I'm not even sure what you
mean by inexplicable if there's a
question to which human beings haven't
arrived at a persuasive consensus answer
such as whether or not we have free will
or what free will even means as a
concept then I'll settle the question to
my own satisfaction and proceed from
there I don't feel that human existence
has any purpose or meaning thus I read
fiction from the perspection perspective
of a moral and metaphysical nihilist if
I can't settle a question or if it
doesn't interest me it won't have a
place in my life now isn't that
interesting let's dwell on that one for
a moment and you do see this uh in in
his uh
um you know conspiracy against the human
race legati will stake out his position
he's fine if other people have other
positions because he realizes that um
you know different people are going to
arrive at different conclusions and that
there's an awful lot involved in the
reasoning process disease usually under
the Surface by which they get to those
right and that logic by itself is not
going to supply you with the answers and
you're not going to have some sort of uh
Universal consensus on any of these
matters right then he's asked about
another term so inexplicable nothing
inexplicable he's asked what does the
word ambiguity mean to you as a fiction
writer he says
doesn't mean anything to me as far as I
I'm aware neither does Irony as a writer
I've I've tried to be as straightforward
as possible with respect to how I want a
reader to feel and what I want a reader
to think after reading one of my stories
and then finally this is a really
interesting one what are your thoughts
on something like Joseph Campbell's
hero's journey right and he says well
heroic fiction is a peculiar John genre
in which I indulged on only one occasion
being me I had the hero triumph over his
adversary which I characterized as
something like the life principle by
killing himself in a manner relevant to
the story
and then he goes on and he says I
believe that the figure of the hero and
the outline of his journey belongs
strictly to mythologies designed to
indoctrinate people into a positive
vision of life these Journeys are
adapted from an evolutionary perspective
the journeys my characters take are
always one of Decline and death which is
the Journey of average individuals
and also I believe will be the Journey
of the human race as a whole so he's
rejecting or at least you know saying
it's kind of irrelevant to me this this
silliness about the hero's journey right
um it's for people who don't want to
face up to what reality actually looks
like I have to admit I'm a little bit
you know tempted to take on that
critique of Campbell and the hero's
journey that so many people seem to to
lap up in love uh going on there's
another very interesting interview uh
from the hat rack
he's asked you write fiction about the
darkness of the world and you had so
many have gained great pleasure from
your Works myself included how can you
reconcile this is there something wrong
with enjoying such dark fiction some
kind of suicidal mechanism that makes
the rare defective organism enjoy being
told of its inadequacies
so Legato says your question implies
there's an ideal human against Those
whom re those who read dark fiction may
be compared but there is no such
organism
all human beings are randomly generated
arbitrary arbitrarily conditioned units
what we would call defects in a given
individual is probably best measured by
characteristics relevant to its Fitness
to survive and reproduce everything else
has to do with psychological or
sociological conventions and
peculiarities
by the broad conventions of modern
Western Civilization reading dark
fiction is a form of Escapist diversion
like any other in a sense it might be
considered one of many survival
mechanisms we employ to burn off the
cognitive excess endemic to our species
we think too much and thinking is the
destroyer of what we need to live and
what we need are irrational immediate
Pleasures or an unreasoning Prospect of
the same
nothing of great importance in our lives
what we consider makes them worth living
is rational this includes pleasurable
emotions and Sensations derived from a
variety of sources such as sex without
reproductive purpose mountain climbing
and rock and roll
without these and other irrational
enjoyments life is not worth living for
human beings you could even add to the
previous list irrational activities that
are not usually considered hedonistic
devoting ourselves to the well-being of
others from whose survival we seem to
have nothing to gain prayer or
meditation intended to release us from
an egoistic survivalist way of life
reproducing more human beings for the
continuance of a race that cannot be
proved to be worth continuing and so on
all these irrational actions are of the
conventional sort and their purpose is
not often questioned
as for psychological or sociological
peculiarities reading dark fiction to
burn off the cognitive excess endemic to
our species is frequently viewed as a
perverse Pastime that is especially
irrational and practiced with enthusiasm
by only a small Cadre of human beings
although it does serve a survival need
as an Escapist form of diversion like
any other it does so in a roundabout
manner that on its face is indefensible
and at a deeper level is a negation of
what makes life worth living
So reading dark fiction is a degenerate
Indulgence that Revels in what is
against human life
then he goes on and he tells a personal
story
when I was a child reading horror novels
or horror comic books I was told by my
parents a priest was coming to visit our
house immediately gathered up my horror
comics and hid them under the cushion of
one of the living room sofas when the
priest entered the house he was invited
by my parents to sit down of course he
sat on the cushion of the sofa beneath
which I'd hid my horror comics I was
terrified because I believed he knew
what I had hidden there I was a very
religious child and I felt intensely
reading those horror comics was a sin
and he goes on
it was I felt it was diabolical for me
to be enjoying horror comics for the
same reason you asked me if it was
irreconcilable to take pleasure in
Reading dark fiction and wallowing in
the darkness of the world because it's
diabolical and irreconcilable
years later when I started writing
horror fiction I asked one of my
co-workers who was a born-again
Christian if he thought I was doing
something sinful
he was someone I considered a work
friend and had conversely with honesty
uh conversation with honesty on a
variety of subjects he said he didn't
think that writing horror fiction was
was sinful later he wrote a book on the
conservative uh thinker Russell Kirk who
wrote what I would describe as moral
horror stories maybe my work friend
didn't think writing or fiction was
sinful because he was thinking of moral
horror fiction which is mostly the kind
of horror fiction that's written the
point is that even when I was in my 20s
and an atheist I still wondered if
enjoying horror fiction was sinful
sinful and wrong
some sometime later in life I'd cease to
care whether reading or writing horror
fiction was wrong I'd read all sorts of
literature that was considered sick and
evil and I loved it because it was sick
and evil and I loved it because it was
against the human race and its values
perhaps that's why other readers of
horror fiction or at least certain kinds
of horror fiction get pleasure from it
they can only answer for themselves you
have my confession and in that we get an
answer to this seeming paradoxicality of
giving pleasure to others through
writing about the darker side of life
then finally we have this very
interesting discussion that's happening
in the dark arts Journal
Xavier Reyes is is asking questions and
says many labels have been used to
define you and your work for example
nihilus pessimist misanthropic
how do you feel towards them is there a
better one to encapsulate your worldview
and legati says well I feel fine about
being referred to as a pessimist in a
philosophically unsophisticated my sense
my pessimism doesn't have a metaphysical
basis like Chopin hours will to live
which I never understood as a reading of
the universe that would necessarily lead
one to a grim view of life to me it
seems closely related to bergson's Alan
vital at the same time I've used the
idea of Anima Mundi and a few stories to
represent the same kind of driving force
as the world live with the difference
that it's a personal evil not an
indifferent type of energy that makes
the world move as it does schopenhauer's
will to live is as difficult to swallow
as any other monist explanation for
anything right and then he texts about
pan psychism
and he says that it posits Consciousness
as a universal all-pervading phenomena
that is the underlying reality of
everything we know or can know though
it's perceived by only a few individuals
who are somehow tuned to its existence
and he goes on and he says such persons
are rewarded with an insight into a
metaphysical reality that supersedes all
others and then he says even
philosophers of mine like strawson and
Chalmers of entertained pan psychism as
a viable metaphysical explanation of
human consciousness if only because it
can resolve what Chalmers calls the
so-called hard problem of explaining the
gap between physical materialism and
immaterial Consciousness and now notice
what he says
I couldn't care less about metaphysical
matters that are so monumentally
inevident
and then he says mad then again most of
us would say the same about
philosophical pessimism whose sole
contention is that the suffering of
sentient beings absolutely negates the
value of life
one can only agree
or disagree with this philosophy the
foundation of pessimism is not a matter
of logic or truth except when it
Ventures into matters of metaphysics
ontology epistemology morality or any of
the other areas of interest that
philosophers see as their remit and
purpose and most pessimists do Venture
into these areas if only to provide an
answer as to why life is as awful as
they judge it to be but they can never
succeed in their task by taking these
roots
and then he says it's very much the same
with nihilists their concern is with
meaning and values that is the absence
endangerment or disappearance of these
components of human life if suffering
were to be eliminated then meaning and
values would not be needed in our lives
Hedonism is enough to keep us going and
the pleasures of the world have been
judged sufficient if only has something
to seek
um and that he he goes on and he says
should you find yourself suffering badly
enough no meaning or value can help you
but if you're in a state of psycho
physical and emotional well-being
that meaning and value are unnecessary
outside of providing ideas that
consolidate individuals or societies and
their self-image particularly in
relation to the self-images of other
individuals and societies and you know
he goes on a little bit further and says
that you know all of this I don't see
this as casting me as a misanthrope it's
just a grandiose aspiration of an
ordinary
pessimist
then he's asked uh and he gives a long
answer to this is there anything that
weird or Supernatural fiction can do
that realist fiction cannot he says
this was an invitation to pontificate
and I'll try to answer without wandering
too far any distinction between
Supernatural fiction in its various
subtypes and realist fiction is
non-existent except in the trivial sense
of differentiating among literary genres
and the perceived quality of Works
belonging to one or the other in terms
of Aesthetics intelligence subject
matter and so on
the question itself is certainly of the
exclusive concern of readers and critics
of Supernatural Fiction with an
inferiority complex regarding the value
of writings for which they have an
inexplicable sensitivity and
appreciation
the more important division
is between what we consider the
supernatural as opposed to the real
in philosophy this division can be seen
as an argumentation between thinkers who
as an instance defend idealism against
materialism
most broadly the conflict is between the
Supernatural and the natural
in an interview with Jorge Louis Borges
the Argentinian writer was asked about
how much the depictions of fantastic
worlds in his fiction reflected his own
beliefs his answer was this
we don't know if the universe belongs to
a realist genre or a fantastic one
my interpretation of Borge's response is
not whether the universe is real or
fantastic but whether our consciousness
of the universe perceives the universe
as real that is material and dualistic
or Supernatural meaning fantastic in a
probably non-dual sense of the term
while my view is that human beings are
Parts things of Parts like anything else
I also think that consciousness of
ourselves gives us a supernatural
quality
not possessed by anything else in effect
we are at odds with the natural and even
antagonists towards what we call nature
and he goes on and and he says that um
here we go
um ultimately I agree with Borges along
with philosophers and meditation gurus
who entertain the idea of pan psychism
that we don't know if the universe
belongs to a realist genre or a
fantastic one so we we have to be a
little bit
agnostic means matters right and then
he's asked um what would you say are the
aims of your fiction and he says well
all of my all of my stories have had
their origins in a mood or attitude I
wanted to convey to the reader when I
first began writing I realized my
subject matter would necessarily derive
from my own wife life I've never been a
worldly person thus I never had at my
command either much in the way of
practical knowledge or a wide range of
lived experiences and this has been
mostly due to the psychological
disorders from which I suffered nearly
all my life most specifically from the
age of 17 to the present I've been
subject to clinical mood disorders I can
understand why someone would dismiss
everything I've written as being nothing
more than a symptom of my diagnoses
relating to anxiety and depression
thereby making my literary output all
but worthless
from my side I can't take seriously
literary works that haven't in some
distinctive way emerge from what
purportedly normal people would call an
unhealthy
affects
major and minor works of literature have
been produced by authors at both polls
or along the Continuum of emotional
Wellness or sickness and then he goes on
and he says
um as for my relationship to what I've
written I can't say that this has
changed in any way since my earliest
attempts as a writer certainly my
writings haven't changed and their
emotional or intellectual aspects for
instance the first story I wrote that
didn't find its way to a waste basket is
about an anthropology Professor who
suffers from depression during the
darker months of the year as an academic
project and as a diversion from his
personal Darkness he travels to a small
town to investigate a supernatural cult
whose Mythos is based on the
antenatalist beliefs of the early
Christian gnostics naturally things
don't end well for the professor 40
years later antenatalism is a prominent
theme in my non-fiction book conspiracy
against the human race and a later
pro-mortalist story called metaphysical
morum
and then this is a very interesting and
it's it's good to sort of close with if
we were to press you for one story of
yours that best defines you as a writer
which one would it be
and why
and he says to this question I usually
say the shadow at the bottom of the
world both for its prose style and its
plot of a rural Locale that Harbors a
malignantly anti-human force or
fundamental that is alien and menacing
with respect to human values
so that's legati's own take on if there
is anything that's at the Essence the
Paradigm expressing his own mindset his
musings his work product that's the one
that it would be so a lot of very
interesting insights there that we can
follow out through the philosophical
themes that we see in the selection
we're not going to try to cover every
single narrative that he has generated
but at least
some of them
there are a number of very interesting
philosophical themes running throughout
Thomas legatti's writings his short
stories and the conspiracy on the human
race and also found as we saw in the
interviews with him as well and I'm not
going to claim that this is the most
absolutely Central or important theme
although I do think it's up there if we
wanted to say like the top five or top
ten but one of the themes that I found
by far the most interesting at least at
this point in my reading of legati is
that of the puppet the mannequin the
dummy and how it applies to us and he
treats it in a number of different ways
I think the place to start for us is
indeed the conspiracy against the human
race and this is about halfway through
this is in the chapter who goes there
and he's considering a number of
different
let's call them metaphysical and moral
commitments that most people tend to
make that he thinks are fundamentally
mistaken but it's inevitable that we're
going to fall into them among them is
the idea that we have some sort of
lasting kernel of identity that we call
a self and we've already talked a little
bit about that but another one is the
matter of determinism and you know he
says that in the history of
philosophical Luke abrasion Arguments
for determinism are traditionally the
most argued against why is this so aside
from the fact that it turns the human
image into a puppet image and then he
goes on and he says well you know
there's moral responsibility but I we're
less interested in that at this point
um you know legati is is willing to take
on the idea of determinism and you know
he's not the only uh author to to do so
you know it's it's very interesting to
see that when people Embrace something
like a determinism a determinism for
most people they won't they wind up
getting labeled as being nihilistic and
you could think of you know what we
often call compatibilism you know
there's there's you know libertarianism
saying we do have free will uh if it's
very extreme it says Ah we can decide
anything we want to and then there's you
know determinism at the other side
saying no no everything that we do is
ultimately causally determined and then
there's sort of a middle position that's
a big messy landscape of compatibilism
where it's you know saying well
determinism does hold but maybe we can
be our own causes at times or you know
our freedom goes into a determinism
comes out of it goes back into it and
what does it actually take though for us
to be
free
what would it take for us to be free not
in an absolute sense but just in a
smaller sense to to not be merely a
dummy a mannequin a puppet something
that is controlled by strings by
programming by something else and you
know determinism the threat of it that
it poses to us the worries about us
being puppets is that when we think that
we're free we're actually just
determined to to buy that and legati you
know says something here in this section
it does not seem wildly improbable that
determinations have been made in our
psyches that make some people
determinists and others indeterminous if
we could only know how these
determinations work we would be able to
answer the only interesting question in
the debate pitting Free Will against
determinism Why argue for one side or
the other the answer to this question
would abort all rivalry in this manner
since it would bring to light the reason
why any philosopher would engage in a
conflict more vain than most in his
discipline right and so you know that's
that's an interesting observation
much later in a a chapter called autopsy
on a puppet he talks about uh in horror
stories he says there's an assortment of
figures that appear as Walk-Ons or
extras whose purpose is to lend their
spooky presence to a narrative for
atmosphere alone well the real bogey is
something else altogether puppets dolls
and other caricatures of the human often
make Cameo appearances as shapes sagging
in the corner of a child's bedroom or
lulling on the shelves of a toy store
they're also dismembered Limbs and
decapitated heads of mannequins that
have been relegated to spare parts drawn
about an old Warehouse where such things
are stored or sent to die as backdrops
or bit players imitations of the human
form have a symbolic value because they
seem connected to another world
one that is all harm and disorder the
kind of place we sometimes fear is the
model for our own home ground which we
must believe is possibly sound insecure
or at least not an environment where we
might mistake a counterfeit person
for the real thing
so that's the you know one of the
underlying threats of the dummy right
and he says but in fiction as in life
mistakes are sometimes made when they
are one of those humanoid replicas May
advance to the center of a story's
action and now we get another wrinkle to
this theme and he talks about Hoffman's
the Sandman the protagonist discovers
the two perfect girls who he had
proposed marriage is really just an
automaton this shakes him up so greatly
he's committed to an asylum until he
recovers his senses right
and um he goes on his Hoffman Story Goes
many lovers to be quite convinced they
were not enamored of wooden dolls would
request their Mistresses to sing and
dance a little at a time to embroider
and knit and play with their lap dogs
while listening to reading and above all
not merely to listen but sometimes to
talk in such a manner as presupposed
actual thought and feeling
and he goes on and he says there are
many abominable Fates and horror stories
and among them is that of Nathaniel you
know finding out that you have been
engaging with something that is not
human that is really just a mock-up
but then he says worse still is when a
human being becomes objectified as a
puppet a doll or some other caricature
of our species and enters a world that
he or she thought was just a creepy
little place inside of ours what a jolt
to find oneself a prisoner in this
Sinister sphere reduced to a composite
mechanism looking out on the land of the
human or one which we believe to be
Human by any definition the word and to
be exiled from it just as we know that
dreams are merely reflections of what
happens in our lives we are also quite
sure that puppets dolls and other
caricatures of our species are only
reflections of ourselves in a sane world
no correspondence could exist between
those artificial anatomies and our
natural flesh that would be too strange
and awful for things to be confused in
such a way
more strange and awful of course would
to be to would be to find this a living
confusion life as the dream of a puppets
so you know this is uh putting out a
number of different horrific
possibilities near the end of that
particular essay autopsy on a puppet he
says that
we have long since fallen from Nature's
arm everywhere around us are natural
habitats but within us is the shiver of
startling and Dreadful things simply put
we are not from here if we vanish
tomorrow no organism on this planet
would miss us nothing in nature needs us
and he goes on to talk about main
lenders uh God and he says we move among
living things all those natural puppets
with nothing in their heads but our
heads are in another place a world apart
where all the puppets exist not in the
midst of life but outside of it we are
those puppets those human puppets we are
crazed mimics of the natural prowling
about for a peace that will never be
ours and the medium in which we
circulate is that of the supernatural so
this theme of the the puppet turns out
to be quite important and let's actually
take a look at a very recent uh
in involvement with this which has to do
with the smalls the little people right
and this is in the spectral link
it's one of the two stories in there and
it begins with the narrator
being accused of being a bigot by his
parents he's talking to his doctor and
his uh mother and father resorted to
using the word shameful little bigot
quite a lot why because they were on
vacation and they saw a car full of
little people who are you know growing
into uh the world that they know small
small country is the name of that and
I'm not going to try to summarize the
entire thing but
it's interesting there's there's a whole
discussion here of going to the library
and trying to uncover information about
these people and he says in no time at
all I could find out all I needed to
know about the small people and possibly
what I learned with Terminator at least
temper my fear of them or even alleviate
or dissolve entirely my hatred of their
kind so he's trying to you know
self uh therapize himself out of these
uh
emotions that not only is he feeling and
not happy with but his parents are
responding to as well
and he says
I could hardly find a mention of these
creatures not even in the form of
Records or statistics relating to them
ultimately I was forced to conclude
nothing was being hidden for me or the
rest of the world at least it wasn't
being hidden deliberately consciously
that would have been an impossible task
and he says I'm not saying no one has
ever ruminated on the phenomenon of the
small people no doubt everyone has
pondered their existence at some time or
another but such considerations have
never been sustained long enough to
create a body of inquiry and knowledge
before pen could be put to paper an
expedition launched some negating in
curiosity set in that dissipated any
spur to action or any action that
resulted in authoritative books and
peer-reviewed essays and specialized
journals
and so what he's recognizing here is
that you know although people know about
the small people nobody seems that
interested in them he meets a friend who
also dislikes fears hates the small
people and they actually have a
confrontation right so they wind up
running into these people after spying
on them and here's a description
um they didn't speak a word neither to
us nor amongst one another nothing
shocked me about that but it did add to
the disorienting unreality of the
situation for a time they stayed in
place paradoxically they appeared
gigantic gigantic for toys given their
toy like aspect
their clothes seemed painted on them
their faces were so smooth gleaming in
the Moonlight without any of the
characteristic qualities of Flesh they
were also unwrinkled unworn by time and
somehow Immortal that is how they had
always been created somehow but not
developed in stages from birth to their
present age there had been no process of
coming to age for them I thought later
no birth or death are all the things in
between that trouble our own existence
or at least troubled us when we attended
to them there was only going through the
motions a pretense of life
in a way they were a mirror of us of
what we wanted for ourselves they marked
time and nothing else time to do this
time to do that time to make an another
town time to relocate having poisoned a
new landscape with small country
and later on and this is why he's
talking to a doctor he's going to
realize the implications of him being
adopted he comes to see and there is a
spectral link between him and the small
people that
in addition to human beings and Smalls
there's an intermediary category
he says
um
I realized
that about half of the people in town as
real and half as halfers
half small people half real and he gets
very good at telling that and then he
realizes that his parents are
heifers
he talks about his his father and his
mother
saying uh
though the Sun was shining on my
mother's smooth face her big eyes
weren't squinting they didn't look left
or right up or down they were just big
eyes like a big doll would have the
longer I sat with my parents eating
hamburgers hot dogs and potato salad
you know my parents did what they had to
do in order to be real parents to me but
we weren't biologically related I was
adopted as an infant and now I knew I
was only a prop
something to Aid them and not being
found out for what they were
and so he goes in and eventually he's
finding his parents in bed it must have
been about the middle of the night when
I entered my mother and father's bedroom
they were lying on their backs in bed
the Moonlight glowing in my father's
slightly smiling face and concentrating
stare as well as on my mother's smooth
face and big eyes which were open both
their eyes were open I don't know why
maybe they didn't sleep it wasn't as if
I was the sort of person to peek into
his parents bedroom to see what they
were doing
He says Dad Mom listen I want to tell
you something
and then he says I'm a shameful little
bigot I hate the small people I hate
them for all I'm worth but more than I
hate the small people I hate you then I
jumped on the bed and was all over them
with knives I'd gotten from the kitchen
push push push chop chop chop they
didn't make a sound the whole time I can
tell you one thing halfers aren't soft
like the smalls I really had to work on
those things
that called themselves my parents
right so
a confrontation motivated by hate and
fear
between a child adopted by half
mannequins half Smalls
uh let's talk about another interesting
uh set of stories so in uh noxuary we
have this uh mad Knight of atonement and
here we actually have a you know
Professor or doctor whatever whatever we
want to call them and he is
um there it is Dr Frank Francis
hoxhausen right a scientist and he
brings people in to check out his new
invention but he begins with a story
says I'd like to open my lecture with
the following anecdote there's a legend
that I learn while traveling here and
there it seems there was a sorcerer an
alchemist who dreamed of transforming
the world through the creation of an
artificial man
this man the sorcerer dreamed would not
be subject to the flaws and limitations
of the former typo it would instead live
through many lifetimes accumulating the
knowledge and wisdom it would one day
use to serve and improve the human race
the sorcerer like all dreamers of this
kind was intent on his vision and not
particularly concerned with its
ramifications in a larger scheme of
things so he goes to to build it we'll
talk about we're going to skip over that
a little bit
and then we find it was not long after
this regimen that the omnipotent one
realized what the sorcerer was intending
to do and so it happened that the
creature strong and well coordinated but
still a child in its mind was awakened
in the dead of night by a voice that
cursed it as a blasphemy and an
Abomination The Voice bid the creature
to go to its fall maker in the Attic
where he had sequestered himself among
evil books and impure devices confused
and terrified the creature ascended
several stairways and entered the attic
and there he found the sorcerer
sounds like Frankenstein up to this
point doesn't it but there's a big twist
he found the sorcerer motionless and
hung on the wall like something in a
puppet Maker's Workshop his dark robe
grazing the dusty floor and his head
drooping down acting upon a mechanical
impulse Beyond dread or despair the
creature raised his master's head and
saw it was now no more than wood and wax
the site was a maddening one and it did
not take long for the creature to find
the rope with which it hung itself from
the rafters of the Attic So this you
know playing God you could say leads to
being transformed back into mere
material on the part of the Sorcerer And
then what is the actual invention so uh
it's it's a array and there's all these
uh puppets right there's a stage area
occupied by imitations of the human
image puppets and marionettes were
strung up at various elevations relieved
of their weight by fragile glistening
threads mannequin post posed in a
paralyzed Leisure which looked at once
grotesque and idyllic other dummies in
an odd assortment of dolls sad in
miniature chairs here and there simply
sprawled about the floorboards sometimes
propping each other back to back but
among these mock people as it became
evident the longer one gazed at the
stage were hidden real ones who rather
ably imitated the imitations
so he says you see how things are ladies
and gentlemen whereas we have been
dreaming so long of creating perfect
life in the laboratory the Creator holds
sacred only the crude facts simile which
Echoes or expresses his own will he has
always been far ahead of us envisioning
a completed work at the end of history
and he has no more time to linger over
the vital stage of universal Evolution
because no truth or life can exist in us
as we are for truth in life can exist
only in the mind the will of the Creator
and we have stubbornly made it our
business to do nothing but oppose that
mind that will
we are simply the raw material for his
beloved puppets which reflect a
Perfection the truth of the Creator and
are the ideal dwellers in his paradise
of ruins
and after his chosen ones are
triumphantly installed in that good
place the creator has some wonderful
stories to tell us as a way to pass the
hours of Eternity
and then he says we may take our place
among the puppets as the Tableau you see
before you will serve to demonstrate for
there are at this moment certain faces
insinuated among this elect company that
do not
belong that stand out in an unpleasant
way how to bring them into the fold is
the question and the answer if you will
turn for a moment and direct your eyes
towards the balcony the answer Spotlight
is the puppet machine
right the thing that will transform
those into puppets now he says this is
not an everlasting conversion right
but for a little while it turns people
into puppets
isn't that an interesting Prospect
now let's talk about just several other
stories as well
um you know dream of a mannequin pretty
easily suggests itself right we have a
psychiatrist who has a Miss Loker who
has been coming to him and
she is having
bad dreams right and she winds up being
in uh in with some some mannequins right
an awesome load of new clothes has
arrived to Adorn a display of mannequins
their unclothed bodies repel her touch
because they are neither warm nor cold
as only artificial bodies can be and she
says time to stop dancing and get
dressed Sleeping Beauties right and the
dream changes before the dresser is able
to put one stitch on the drum dummies
Who Stare at her and stare at nothing
with anticipating eyes right
and what we find is is all this
discussion of what is happening in her
dreams and we have The Uncanny being
mentioned here as well right and the
psychiatrist says you can probably
imagine my reaction to the above psychic
yarn every loose skin I've followed let
me back to you because uh he's talking
to somebody who is very good for uh
not just hypnotizing but planting
suggestions and then a bit later
right
he is going to try to track down Mrs
Loker Miss Loker and uh
isn't able to make a lot of success
right
and what we find then is he starts
having dreams himself
and so here is uh one of them
in the white and hallway
there are things that look like people
dressed as dolls or else dolls made up
to look like people I remember being
confused about which it was and they're
lying up and down the floor the top of
the stairway even on the stairs
themselves as they disappear into the
darker regions below when I emerge from
the bedroom I see their eyes shining in
the white Darkness their heads are
turned in all directions paralyzed yes
with Terror I merely return a fixed gaze
wondering if my eyes are shining the
same as theirs and here's where the
horror comes in
then one of The Doll People slouching
against the wall on my left turns its
head haltingly on a stiff Little Neck
and look straight at me worse it talks
and its voice is a horrible parody of
human speech even more horrible are its
words when it says
become as we are sweetie die into us
suddenly I began to feel very weak as if
my life were being drained out of me
summoning all my willpower I managed to
rush back to my bed which ends the dream
right and this dream is
an intrusion of The Uncanny into his
life and then you know he goes on and he
says
in Miss Loker I believe you've sent me
an embodiment of your deepest
convictions
suppose that Grant she was somehow a
dream supposedly allow she was not a
girl but actually a thing without a self
and unreality that in accord with your
vision of existence dreamed it was a
human being and not just a fabricated
impersonation of our flesh you would
have Me Entertain such thoughts you
would have me think there's some
mysterious Affinity among the things of
this world and other worlds so what if
there is I I don't care anymore
right so this is interesting it's almost
like legati and talking to this other
character
is talking to his own views on things he
believes we don't actually have selves
he believes that our Consciousness is
something too much you know sort of a
blot on existence that leads us to
believe in all sorts of things that
aren't really the case
let's look at two other stories and then
maybe we'll have to wrap up because this
is already growing quite long
so in Dr Volk and Mr Veach we have the
two of them meeting up and
um we have a dummy involved right within
the darkness ahead there suddenly
appears a tall rectangle like a ticket
seller's booth at a carnival the lower
part is composed of wood in the upper
part of glass its interior is lit up by
an oily red glare slumped forward on its
seat in the side the booth as if asleep
is A well-dressed dummy nicely fitting
black jacket and vest with bright silver
buttons a white high collar shirt with
silver cuff links and a billowing cravat
which displays a pattern of moon and
stars because his head is forwardly
inclined the dummies only feature of
note is the black Sheen of its painted
hair now notice how well this dummy has
been depicted almost like a human being
right
VH approaches the booth a little
cautiously seems to be most interested
in the figure within through a
semi-circular opening in the glass of
each slides his hand into the booth
apparently with the intention of giving
the dummy's arm a shake
but before his own arm creeps very far
towards its goal several things occur in
succession
the dummy casually lifts its head and
opens its eyes it reaches out and places
its wooden hand on veach's hand of Flesh
and its draw drops open to dispense a
mechanical laugh
resting his hand away from the dummy
Veach staggers backward a few steps the
dummy continues to give forth its
mocking laughter which flaps its way
into every niche of the Loft and flies
back as peculiar Echoes the dummy's face
is vacant and handsome its eyes roll
like mad marbles then from out of the
Shadows behind the dummies Booth step
someone who is every bit as thin as
Veach though much taller his outfit his
outfit is not unlike the dummies but his
clothes hang on him and what there is
left of his sparse hair Falls like torn
Rags across his bow and white scalp
did you ever wonder Mr Veach Volk begins
did you ever wonder
what it is that makes the animation of a
wooden dummy so terrible to see not to
mention to hear listen to it I mean
really listen
a series of sounds that becomes
excruciating excruciatingly eloquent
when uttered by the ticket man they are
a species of poetry that sings What
should not be sung that speaks what
should not be spoken but what in the
world is it laughing about nothing it
would seem no clear motives or impulses
make the dummy laugh and yet it does
but what is the laughter for you might
well ponder it it seems to be for your
ears alone doesn't it it seems to be
directed at every part of your being it
seems knowing and it is knowing but in
another way from what you suppose in
another Direction entirely
it is not you the dummy knows it is only
itself the question is not what is the
laughter for the question is where does
it come from and then he goes on
think about it wood waking up I can't
put it any clearer than that and let's
not forget about the painted hair and
lips the glassy eyes these two are
aroused from a sleep that should never
have been broken these two are now part
of a tingling network of dummy nerves
alive and aware in a way we cannot begin
to imagine this is something too painful
for tears and so the dummy laughs in
your face trying to give vent to a
horror that was no part of his old home
of wood and Paint and Glass but this
horror is the very essence of its new
home our world Mr Veach that is what is
so terrible about the Laughing ticket
man a little bit earlier in that he says
while this dummy does terrorize you his
terror is actually greater than yours so
we have this I mean if if the dummy
remains a mannequin a machine merely
programmed everything's okay for it but
as soon as it has consciousness
it starts to realize what kind of
existence it has and Terror and horror
as part of that
the last thing I'll bring up
is in the story uh netha scurial which
[Music]
um
has a section the puppets in the park
right and he's the the narrator says
that
um
I was walking along an indefinite route
and I came to a clearing with an
audience had assembled for a late night
entertainment strings of colored lights
have been hung the people Seated on
these benches were all watching a tall
illuminated Booth it was the kind of
Booth used for puppet shows with wild
designs painted across the lower part
and a curtained opening at the top the
curtains were now drawn back and two
clownish creatures were twisting about
in a glary light which emanated from
inside the booth they leaned and
squawked and awkwardly bad at each other
with soft paddles they were hugging in
their little arms so far so good right
it's you know I'm seeing people at a
puppet show
and then it turns to horror
suddenly they froze at the height of
their battle slowly they turned around
and faced the audience
okay so now the dummies are
alive conscious and they're facing this
mass of people
it seemed that the puppets were looking
directly at the place I was standing
behind the last row of benches they're
misshapen heads tilted in their glassy
eyes stared right into mine so now it's
not just the audience it's you
then I noticed the others were doing the
same all of them had turned around on
the benches and with expressionless
faces and dead puppet eyes held me to
the spot although their mouths did not
move they were not silent but the voices
I heard were far more numerous than was
the gathering before me they were the
voices I'd been hearing as they chanted
confused words into the depths of
everyone's thoughts fathoms below the
level of their awareness the words still
sounded hushed and slow monotonous
phrases mingling like the sequences of a
fugue but now I could understand these
words as even more voices picked up the
chant at different points and overlapped
one another saying amid the rooms of our
houses across moonlit Skies throughout
all souls and Spirits behind the faces
of the living and the dead
right so
all of us beings
so we see this really centrally
important theme again not necessarily
the absolutely most it's one of many
interesting themes but it is certainly
the one that in my readings of these uh
these stories and uh you know legati's
essay
the conspiracy against the human race
captivated me the most and so given how
much time we've spent on this with I
don't want this to go over long this is
where we have to wrap up so once again
to all those viewers who've been with me
to the end thanks for hanging out we do
these every month and I will say a
special thank you to the people who I
don't remember who recommended and then
voted for incorporating Thomas legatti's
Works into Worlds of speculative fiction
[Music]
thank you